hey guys it is the fifth of November
which those of you who are English or
big fans of V for Vendetta will know is
Guy Fawkes Day I'm jess and here's what
happened in gaming today the Star Wars
FPS first assault may not actually be
happening anymore but a gameplay video
has been posted online to show us what
might have been the 20 minute gameplay
clip of the cancelled game which found
its way onto reddit intersection from a
technical beta which ran on xbox live
back in 2012 the video shows off a map
set on Tatooine as well as first
assaults array of weapons and items no
combat is actually shown in the video as
the uploader said they couldn't spawn
bots or add another player so it's
mostly walking previous reports
indicated that first assault was
designed to be eight step of zero prior
to star wars battlefront 3 to see how
these titles would work on the own
volition development was put on hold
when Disney bought the Star Wars brand
in October of 2013 her blood has
indicated that blizzards upcoming
multiplayer shooter overwatch could be
making its way to ps4 and Xbox one
overwatch was previously only confirmed
for PC the game informer has reported
that retailer gamestop received word
that the game would also be arriving on
current-gen consoles all versions of the
game are priced at 60 bucks and it's
later to launch next year overwatch will
be blizzards first brand new franchise
in 17 years if these reports are true
it's a pretty safe bet that will hear
about it officially at blizzcon which
kicks off tomorrow morning and since
resolutions are a thing that we're
apparently still talking about Just
Cause 3 developer Roland lefland has
come out and talked about which
resolutions we can expect the game to
render in on consoles blast alone told
gamingbolt the game runs at 1080p on ps4
and 900 p on xbox one we do so much with
physics and screen space effects that we
are confident our players will
thoroughly enjoy themselves no matter
the platform they play the game on Just
Cause 3 is the latest in the list of
games which render slightly better on
ps4 those also include Metal Gear Solid
five and the witcher 3 Just Cause 3 is
due out on December one across PC and
consoles let me know down in that
comment section it's the difference
between 900 p and 1080 matters to you
and why you can add two games well we've
got stories on a witch a movie and halo
Phibes microtransactions doing better
than you'd expect that is everything I
have for you today but do you remember
the same time tomorrow I'll have my top
five stories of the whole gaming week
all ready to go for you I'll catch you
then